what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if
you're new here my name is richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming subscribe for all kinds
of content just like this and hit the
notification Bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video I'm gonna
say something that pretty much everybody
knows and it's that data science is
white hot right now and everybody wants
to get into it and they come across the
spectrum there's people in school right
now who are in programs for statistics
computer science business even and
they're looking at data science as a
potential career field same sort of
thing with professionals there's tons of
people in other professions who want to
make lateral style career moves to get
into data science but here's the problem
the real question is how do you get into
data science a big part of the problem
is that the field is so
multidisciplinary I did a video a while
back where I described what data science
really is and I described it as the
intersection of four different skill
sets and those are statistics
programming communication and domain
knowledge but that's just the high level
overview statistics is an extremely
broad field in and of itself and there
are tons of different programming
languages out there and nobody has time
to go to school or get a bunch of
different certifications to learn 13
different programming languages so it's
a totally natural question to ask what
are the most important skills to know
and what's the order of priority so what
I thought would be helpful is to lay out
a study pathway for data science so how
this will work is you start with item
number one learn it after you're done
with that move on to item number two and
so on and so forth that way you have
priorities you have things you can focus
on and you can see yourself becoming
more marketable and more competitive for
your first data science job now you
might know item number two but you don't
know item number one or item number
three and that's totally okay
my recommendation then would be start
with item number one then move on to
item number three now what's my basis
for all of this a lot of it is based on
what I think has made me successful in
my years as
data scientists so far but it's also
based on my own reflection about what I
would have done differently if I could
start over today as well as what the
trends are in data science in the year
2020
now there's people out there who do say
that everybody's pathway to becoming a
data scientist is different and I both
agree and disagree with that
there's certainly tons of variety in the
field and there's people who come into
it from all kinds of different
backgrounds and skill sets so what you
end up with is different flavors of data
science but having said all of that
there are some Universal things which I
think every data scientist must know in
order to be successful so without
further ado let's move on to item number
one item number one is statistics you
really can't argue with how important
statistics is to data science it's
really to me what prevents the field of
data science from being data
pseudoscience and to me things like
programming languages are truly the how
of data science domain knowledge will
give you the why but statistics will
give you the what I did a video all
about how much statistics you really
need for data science if you haven't
seen that check it out I'll have it
linked but in short you need to know
things like probability distributions
Bayes rule confidence intervals
hypothesis tests that way you have a
good solid foundation you also need to
reason your way through problems
you need to know some concepts like
confounding variables and Simpsons
paradox bias variance the assumptions of
different statistical tests and you need
to know different techniques like the
statistical tests themselves and things
like survival analysis machine learning
methods are important too but they get
their own category later for this step
just gloss over them now the question
you're probably asking is how do you
learn statistics well if you're
interested in data science and you're
just now looking at masters programs
statistics is about as good of an option
as you could possibly pick some schools
do offer full-blown data science
programs now but depending on how much
computer science expertise you have you
might even be better
going with the statistics degree over
the straight data science degree and it
just comes down to the fact that there's
a lot more programming and computer
science resources out there than there
are for statistics naturally having a
degree is the best possible option for
learning statistics because you just get
immersed in the field for two or four or
however many years your program is and
if the program is good you'll get the
opportunity to do and try things so
you'll get a healthy balance of both the
theory and the application but at the
end of the day it's important to
actually know your stuff as opposed to
just looking like you know your stuff
just because you have a fancy degree and
if you just don't have the time or the
money to go to school you need to find
some other options and the next best
thing is probably Coursera courses
there's several very popular options out
there there's one from Duke University
there's one from John Hopkins University
and there's one from the University of
Amsterdam links to all of these will be
in the description all right so you've
got a good foundation in statistics you
know the frameworks you know the tools
maybe even you know some theory now item
number two on the study pathway is
sequel now why would I suggest that you
learn sequel before you learn the more
mainstream programming languages like R
or Python well there's three reasons for
that first of all is a psychological
reason sequel is almost universally
considered to be easier than R or python
r you don't have the problem of
constantly learning new packages and
even to somebody with no coding
expertise whatsoever sequel reads
basically like the English language and
it's pretty easy to pick up secondly
sequel just prepares you for the real
world data collected in the real world
is really messy it lives in all kinds of
different environments often times with
different primary keys and sequel just
equips you to deal with those kinds of
challenges and third you could easily be
in a situation where the work that you
would do in R or Python is downstream
that is maybe your data live in a sequel
server database environment and then you
have to query different data sets from
there first in order to create a working
day
set after that point you could do things
like models and algorithms and the
typical stuff that you would do in our
Python but if you can't use the sequel
to get to that functional data set in
the first place then you have all kinds
of trouble so this step should hopefully
be a pretty quick and easy thing to
learn and you absolutely don't have to
be a master database architect or sequel
guru in order to be an effective data
scientist but you obviously need to know
how to query your data that means
knowing things like joining data sets
case when statements exist statements
window functions nested queries stuff
like that also storing temporary sets
we're going for function over form here
for the most part alright so now you
know sequel you're able to effectively
query your data now moving on to item
number three and you already saw this
one coming it's one of our or Python I
did a video recently on where the R vs
Python battle stands in the year 2020
and I did conclude that Python is a bit
more of a hot job market item right now
just because R seems to have declined a
little bit in the last two to three
years however I'm not going to tell you
which one of our vs. Python you should
learn first you need to make that
decision yourself based on your own
educational background and your own
interests here's the deal you don't want
to get yourself into a position where
you're trying to learn two things at
once if you don't have background in
either of them it's very difficult to
learn two things at once and you're much
better off being an expert at one thing
rather than being mediocre at two things
if you're coming from a stats background
you probably learned are along the way
and likewise if you're coming from a
more computer science or programming
background you probably picked up Python
if that's the case you're probably best
off sticking with that language and
mastering it so learn one of these two
from beginning to end you're going to
want to know the overall fundamentals of
the language how to tidy and manipulate
your data set how to create
visualizations reports models all of
that and both of these languages have
key data science related packages if
you're learning are a good starting
point is probably
tidy verse and then if you're learning
Python some good starting points would
probably be pandas numpy scikit-learn
Seabourn matplotlib and stats models
alright so at this point you know
statistics you know sequel and you know
one of our or Python at this point
you're in an extremely good position to
get started in data science you're not
gonna get every single job listing that
you see on LinkedIn and you still have
tons to learn frankly you always will
however you are in a position where you
can tackle tons of problems from
beginning to end and you have an
extremely strong foundation so with the
rest of these items I'm putting them in
a rough order of importance but I want
to give you the freedom to rearrange
them based on what interests you and
what kind of data scientists you want to
be item number four is the other one of
our or Python so you do need to be an
expert at one of these two but if you're
an expert at both of them or at least
you know enough of the other one to be
dangerous all of a sudden you are
extremely employable let's face it some
companies just have our infrastructure
set up and they're not switching to
Python anytime soon and the other way
around of that is true to some companies
have been using Python forever and they
just have no use in their ecosystem for
our there is evidence that are is
declining a little bit while Python is
growing but since R is still preferred
in academia and in research and since
some firms do have our studio server
infrastructure set up our and Python are
still the two juggernauts of the data
science world and I don't see that
changing anytime soon so if you know
both the fact that some companies
strictly use one or the other becomes
irrelevant you'll be able to match
exactly what that company needs item
number five is linear algebra now this
is a pretty interesting one if you work
in any kind of research capacity or even
if you're just working in a firm that's
developing brand new products it might
not be enough to rely on existing
algorithms and methods you
have to innovatively create your own
solutions and in that case you need to
get creative and you need to come up
with ideas that are rooted in strong
mathematics and sound science the field
of mathematics that's going to support
you the most with these endeavors is
linear algebra and also just having a
strong understanding of it is gonna have
massive crossover benefits to your
ability to utilize linear models and
machine learning methods this is another
one of those things for which an
education is ideal but it's not a total
requirement one book that I do recommend
is the no BS guide to linear algebra
like everything else the link will be in
the description item number 6 is UX and
design principles now almost everybody
would agree that communication is a
major part of the data science puzzle
that means you can form a relationship
with your client but also that you can
create understandable visualizations
reports just things like that such that
real-life humans can understand and
absorb information and data that you
present everybody knows that there's a
giant technical side of data science but
don't overlook the fact that there's a
massive human side to it which is just
as important if not more important so
what I would recommend is to read some
books on the principles of user
experience
I will also rope in here learning the
principles of solid data visualization
so reading some books like the visual
display of quantitative information by
Edward Tufte day or show me the numbers
by Stephen whew will pay enormous
dividends for you as well item number
seven is everybody's favorite thing and
that is of course machine learning so
I'm listing this category last because
the importance of it is probably a
little bit overstated compared to some
other skills and some companies will
even have full-blown machine learning
engineers and data scientists will
barely even get to dabble in the fun
themselves but that's probably the
exception rather than the rule you also
need to have some background in some of
the items I've listed so far before you
even think about machine learning so
that would include statistics one of our
or Python and probably some linear
algebra as well but there's no
question that more and more companies
are beginning to incorporate machine
learning into their products and
services so for absolute starters I have
to recommend the absolute classic
machine learning course on Coursera by
Andrew egg you'll implement your own
algorithms you'll learn some of the
theory behind the most popular
algorithms and you'll just come away
with a solid fundamental understanding
of machine learning breaking this one
down a little bit you do need to
understand what gradient descent is and
how that works and for some of the most
popular algorithms you really need to be
able to explain in the simplest English
possible what these algorithms are
actually doing for unsupervised learning
methods that would be things like
k-means clustering or hierarchical
clustering for supervised learning that
would be methods like K nearest neighbor
decision trees random forest you get the
idea now if you get really good at these
things you might even be able to
implement these things from scratch
luckily that's already done in the
packages we use in our and Python so
generally you don't have to do that
where I personally think the biggest
value is going to come from in all of
this is being able to explain the
intuition behind these methods and to
attack any given problem that you have
in the smartest possible way whether
your goal is inference or prediction for
example in the real world you'll always
start by setting up your data set then
you can choose the right machine
learning methods based on things like
the dimensionality and the class balance
of your data after that point you can
train and tune your models in ways that
make sense
evaluate based on appropriate metrics
and then you can iterate just based on
how much time you have to spend on the
problem so that's your study pathway to
become a successful data scientist item
number one is statistics item number two
is sequel item number three is R or
Python these are the core fundamentals
that you must know after at that point
you have a little bit of flexibility to
figure out what flavor of data
scientists you want to be now you can
reorder these a little bit based on your
own preferences but what I would
recommend next is item number four learn
the other one of our or Python item
number five is linear algebra
item number six is UX and design
principles and then item number seven is
machine learning this is by no stretch
of the imagination a comprehensive list
there are tons of things which I'm
leaving out here such as SAS or Julia or
Big Data technologies like spark or
MapReduce or things like cloud computing
and that's not to say that none of those
things are important everything is and
it's extremely important to have a
continuous learning mindset but having
said that this field is absolutely
saturated with things that you're
expected to learn and nobody can know
every single thing I do think if you
know these things though you are setting
yourself up for success so thanks for
watching this video let me know what you
think in the comment section and if you
haven't already smashed the like button
then I'll see you all next time until
then Richard on data